[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
one
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
did
[Music]
this
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hi everyone i'm ruth braham and welcome
to the mediquest gaming showcase
the walking dead saints and center is
launched two years ago and millions of
you have since carved a path through new
orleans in an effort to either save the
city or to condemn it
while actions have consequences and sky
dance interactive is back with chapter 2
retribution
new orleans is now a city more dangerous
than ever got more walkers fewer
resources and a bloodthirsty threat that
stocks your every step
saints and centers chapter 2 will be out
later this year so let's take an early
look at your winter vacation
[Music]
a broken man
he is capable of anything
cruelty
viciousness
slaughter
some are horrified by what i've done
but you
tourists are the real monsters
the things you have broken cannot be
mended
for every action
there is consequence
and when i finally find you
tourist
you will see what a broken man
has to offer
[Music]
uh uh
[Music]
[Music]
i'm sure you've heard us talk a lot
about the metaverse over the last few
months and like we said at connect
gaming is how a lot of people are going
to step into it for the first time
games have pioneered many of the
principles that ground our vision
virtual three-dimensional spaces that
enable people to connect in entirely new
ways
we think the metaverse will build on
this foundation to become the next
generation of the internet and the next
evolution in social technology
both the hardware and software need more
work and it may take five to ten years
to fully bring it to life
but gangs exist now
and today is all about gaming
everything you see today is slated to
release within the next year
some of them you're already looking
forward to and others are brand new like
this next one
[Music]
today status pro is announcing nfl pro
era
the first officially licensed nfl game
to hit vr
this is your opportunity to step onto
the field and lead your team to victory
as an nfl quarterback
your favorite teams your favorite nfl
players experience what it's really like
to play at the highest level
here's an exclusive look at what's in
store
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm lamar jackson
[Music]
you could never overlook me believed in
myself
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
get ready crewmates because inner sloth
robot teddy and shell games are bringing
among us to quest 2 this holiday
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
there's more shell games have partnered
with us on some really cool titles like
i expect you to die to and until you
fall and we're not slowing down
today i'm excited to announce that we're
partnering with shell games to bring
three more titles to meta quest over the
next two years
you know when i started here in 2014 we
didn't really know if vr would take off
we worked hard to find developers who
were even interested in taking a chance
on us on this new industry
it was developers like shell games and
so many others who took those first
steps and believed in our platform
a big thank you to shell games for their
continued partnership and for making
such amazing games over the years
and these next few announcements are in
the same vein
developers returning to vr and using
what they've learned to create bigger
and more ambitious sequels
when red matter launched in 2019 it
really showed off what was possible on
quest
it was unique eerie a surreal adventure
set on one of saturn's moons
and it was jaw dropping like some of the
best visuals we had ever seen on quest
now vertical robot is back with red
matter two
they've really outdone themselves the
story picks up right where the first
game ended on an adventure that spans
the solar system from a base on our own
moon to a space station in orbit over
saturn's rings
you'll uncover dark secrets as you race
to stop the unstoppable that mysterious
red matter that now threatens the
universe
let's take a look at red matter too
[Music]
wake up
i know you can
open your
eyes i i can't believe it worked
sasha
is that you
[Music]
we've received a distress signal from
your crewmate on stroke n3
you have a new mission
find him and bring him home
why would they build a research facility
way out here
my reports show nothing
that sector should be deserted
[Music]
something just doesn't add up
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i can't control it
sasha
sasha
[Music]
do you read me
[Music]
aspire 1 vr operative became one of
2019's must-play games
pairing tense stealth action mechanics
with the type of globe chatting story
you'd expect from someone with a three
number code name
tripwire interactive and digital load
are back with a sequel aspire too
your mission should you choose to accept
it is to plunge back into the world of
international espionage for a series of
brand new action-packed single-player
missions
or if you want to bring a friend along
aspire 2 will also feature a separate
co-op campaign with unique missions set
in some familiar aspire-1 environments
so team up with a fellow agent for a
thrilling story that bridges the gap
between aspire 1 and aspire 2.
here's the debut trailer
the year is 2036 automation has ruined
the lives of billions
in australia the espire program is
resurrected to take down the techno
terrorist network opus
your code name is poe
nobody knows you're alive
and nobody can know
you will take control of espionage
and shut office down but first it's time
to select your frame
choose to be a formidable foe in combat
causing mayhem within enemy ranks
or fly under the radar using an array of
smart tools
choose
we've got nothing left to stop them
besides you drop your weapon now
poe
we need you
time is running out we only have ten
days
nine eight seven six
assimilate infiltrate eliminate 2022
[Music]
next i invited a special guest a heroic
sidekick a personal friend of mine to
give you an update on her new adventure
she's a bit nervous for her first
interview so let's all give a warm
welcome to quill
quill's here today
actually would you like me to do the
honors
phil is here to officially announce that
moss book 2 will be coming to quest two
this summer
exciting right
[Music]
this new adventure picks up right where
we left off inside the hex castle in the
arcane and
what's that quilt
[Music]
yeah absolutely
so quill brought some gameplay footage
from moss book 2 to share with us
let's take a look
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay i love it those ripper enemies so
intimidating and that sword dash ability
is that hard to do
we make a great team don't we
so keep an eye out for moss book 2 this
summer and thanks for stopping by quill
[Music]
this next game comes from kyoto-based
developer character bank a first-person
action rpg ruins magus takes place in a
flourishing fantasy city and the ruins
underneath
as a novice wizard seeking to become a
powerful magus you'll set out in search
of long forgotten artifacts
and along the way you'll learn new magic
abilities confront powerful guardians
and even unravel a few mysteries in this
heroic tale
the hand-drawn art style in this game is
just so cool so let's take a look at
ruins magus coming to quest too
[Music]
soon
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
for more than 30 years now the city
builder genre has kept aspiring urban
planners and maybe a few professionals
up late laying down roads running subway
lines placing hospitals in schools
really just creating the perfect cities
but what if you can visit your creations
and see the streets come to life
we haven't seen many city builders yet
and cities vr is setting the bar by
bringing the acclaimed city skylines
over from pc
starting next week you can build the
city of your dreams from the ground up
exclusively on quest 2.
[Music]
when resident evil 4 launched in october
last year it became the fastest selling
game in quest history
but even before launch we heard you
asking well what about the mercenaries
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
yes
i'm pleased to share that the
mercenaries will now launch after
today's showcase as a free update for
anyone who owns resident evil 4 on quest
2.
you can now revisit this fan favorite
horde mode and score big by taking out
as many ganatos as possible before the
helicopter arrives and you complete a
safety this updated version of the
mercenaries was entirely rebuilt for vr
by armature studio in partnership with
my team oculus studios and capcom
and features vr exclusive online
leaderboards and 20 all new challenges
to test the skills of any die hard
complete these challenges to unlock all
sorts of awesome things like a big head
mode
or a black and white classic horror mode
my personal favorite the new golden gun
skins which the team custom made for vr
players
and best of all you can bring all of
these unlocks back to the main campaign
so if you haven't experienced this vr
masterpiece yet there's never been a
better time to pick up resident evil 4
on quest 2.
beat saber you love it i love it beat
saber had an incredible 2021 and we want
2022 to be even bigger with more songs
from more of your favorite artist
this year we already put out our fifth
original soundtrack ost5
and a new fallout boy pack
but we've got more planned including our
next mixtape which will feature hit
tracks from edm artists like deadmau5
and marshmallow pendulum and more
check it out now
[Music]
last year there was one game that a lot
of you really wanted to hear about
and good things come to those who wait
today i'm excited to introduce you to
stress level zero's fourth project phone
lab
i'm feeling so strange
[Music]
for the longest
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is
[Music]
[Music]
bonelab is a brand new game built for
quest 2 and pcvr
a genre defining combat simulation where
creativity is key
everything reacts the way you'd expect
it to react in the real world
bonelab takes the physics of bone works
to new heights
so fight run and climb to uncover the
truth about your reality
bonelab will also support mods so
players can enhance their experience
with new maps new weapons and new
avatars i can't wait to see what people
make
phone lab is set to release later this
year so keep an eye out on the store for
updates
[Music]
thanks so much for joining me for the
2022 mediquest gaming showcase
remember the mercenaries is out now as a
free update to resident evil 4.
we're also celebrating with the sale in
the mediquest store so head over there
for some discounts on some great games
we'll have more announcements later this
year but for now i'd like to welcome a
special guest to the show
thanks ruth and thanks to all the
developers who made today possible this
has been an amazing show and i can't
wait to play the new re4 update and the
beatsaber tracks
i'm also excited to share that this
world that i'm standing in right now is
going to be available for download today
as a new home environment for quest
but you know we can't just end the show
without one last world premiere so
remember
if there's something strange in your
neighborhood
what's up
everybody ready
ready
same
[Music]
yep
that's not good
oh great it's moving
where'd it go
i don't have the shot
oh
thank you guys thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thanks for watching
[Music]
you